com ste matto
nel caso qualcuno di voi si stesse
chiedendo che cosa mica centra un intro
del genere con un video del genere la
risposta che non lo so per ora molto
[ __ ] quindi l'ho messo lo stesso di
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono video sono vari jake schiphol
sabato scorso non ho messo blog perché
ho avuto la febbre è in realtà ancora
non sto benissimo ma la febbre quella
pesante ma è passata avevo registrato
durante la settimana varie cose che mi
sono successe anche nel mentre che avevo
la febbre
però poi non ho caricato il blog perché
il sabato sono stato proprio male male
non son riuscito a montare niente ho
deciso quindi di far uscire oggi un blog
che raccoglie più o meno quello che è
successo durante questa settimana così
vi faccio anche l'annuncio quello
veramente figo questo sabato ragazzi non
uscirà un blog per che uscirà la nuova
parodia con ipantellas l'ultima
l'abbiamo fatta l'anno scorso ed è stata
maroni pieni che ha fatto tipo 7 milioni
di visualizzazioni quindi andata una
bomba speriamo anche che questa vi
piaccia comunque vi faccio vedere un po
di backstage e robe che sono successe
durante la settimana partiamo però da
inizio settimana dove ero sul set di
gabry ponte quanti casi di canzoni ho
fatto in sto periodo
nella mattina ci svegliamo la mattina
addormento cinque ore che per me come
averne dormite una vi sto facendo bella
lo faccio per voi ragazzi io intanto mi
conto rossi o no per smarty bene il naso
il naso di lorenzo mi è molto simpatico
ti piace vero questo caso lo sto meglio
il suo naso ormai di di lui ma anche
tutte le ragazze con le quali sono stato
lasciato solo il mio lato e poi non
arrivano da noi c'è una buona nomea
dietro i nasi grosso ma cosa si può o
non si può dire tranne
grazie avermi fatto fare le views allora
ieri abbiamo rimontato con giulia penna
tutto il giorno che brutto questo è un
lavoro veramente difficile
allora ragazzi vi spiego
siamo praticamente in un hamburgeria e
stiamo registrando il videoclip della
nuova canzone di gabry ponte io lo sto
squilleranno non so neanche se posso
farlo ma me ne sbatto il cazzo e siccome
questo video clip ci sono io come
protagoniste praticamente sono il
fidanzato di lei è stato proprio il
lavoro più bello la mia vita sono mai
stato così fiero di essere uno youtube e
adesso le chiediamo in diretta che cosa
ne pensa della limonata andiamo a
chiederlo giulia da ac le tue
impressioni per il blog come è stato
limonare con mezzo tutto il giorno a
levi grazie grazie me lo dicono tutte mi
sono svegliato stamattina con la febbre
è bello mi chiamo notice degli esenti
che veramente vorrei sting morire
praticamente stamattina mi sono
svegliato presto per montare il video di
che sta renderizzando nel po montato il
video con la febbre è stato difficile mi
chiamo ntare vi do la febbre è veramente
come andare tipo scuola con la sempre
cioè naro tra di cazzi in questo momento
sta finendo di renderizzare ciò vuol
dire che tra poco mi dovrò alzare andare
al computer e caricarlo e non so dove
troverò la forza di parma che si finisce
di renderizzare con la barra verde il
video è finito
se vi definito lo devo cavalcare perché
se non locali con la gente si incazza e
se la gente si incazza poi son cazzi
amari diciamo mi sono svegliato con la
febbre a 39 e io vi assicuro che se ho
la febbre a 37 sono un cadavere quindi
non faccio immaginare come cazzo mi sto
sentendo doveva montare il video finire
di montare video anche velocemente
perché alle 2 passa a prendermi e ron
dobbiamo andare a registrare un video
per dredd finito con red devo prendere
un treno andare dai punt hellas per
registrare una nuova parodia che stiamo
facendo di otranto sto veramente morendo
di oggi vi porto con me perché dovete
assistere al mio disagio con la febbre
e uscito di casa ancora vivo per
miracolo
grazie a dio cerone che fa da tassista
che per adesso sta procedendo bene poi
se sul set sdengo c'è sempre non ho mai
fatto anche da infermiere tutto ok
ragazzi sono arrivati in questo momento
nel paesino dove dovrei incontrare
ipantellas e mi chiedo ma c'è mai
vissuto un essere umano qua da qualche
parte ho lasciato ragazzi che ero in
macchina con just tron
sono passati due giorni e mezzo da
quella volta lì perché sono stati i
seguenti due giorni e mezzo
completamente morto nel letto dalla
febbre è stato veramente orribile sono
usciti praticamente solo oggi che ho
ancora la febbre l'influenza e la tosse
devo registrare una canzone con
ipantellas chiamiamo jacopo
[Musica]
non perché non mi risponde e morto
contemplerà questa busta dell'esselunga
per tutto il tempo ragazzi che due palle
e la con la macchina è fatto i soldi con
youtube e bastardo reazioni c'è il
matrimonio dell'anno
mia nonna e lorenzo favi gera che
attirano grande a riprendere queste cose
che noi stiamo confabulando mi ha detto
che sono un bel giovane si chiamava che
sono altro che c'è un bel giovane e
bello che stai proprio un posteggiatore
volevo interrompere ombra lunga le mani
scusate ragazzi de stefani con disputate
hai visto che di un bel ivan siamo
fotogenici perché la persona fosse
ingenico ragazzi due anni fa era fare il
video con il fantasma di cazzo sono
mosso come dj
va bene che se la mettiamo integrale è
una volta che il ragazzo carino perché
se ti sei rovinato il tempo che i
capelli bellissimi capi duffy g8 se vuoi
mangiamo sushi e poi porco diaz e cazzo
letto
[ __ ] sbagliato sorry sorry cioè e
ciranna fa di peggio e l'ho visto a
maran culo della giunta dai suoi allora
in queste condizioni possibili
non c'è replay c'è poi ma il coach
adesso lo motiverà e non è sbaglierà più
neanche uno
as i ragazzi perché stavo dicendo
appunto che io non studio non vorrei
fare che andare perché faccio schifo non
mi piace fare il vocal coach cioè quello
che spreme bravo così va aggredisci la
pratica
devi avvicinati di più devi girare un po
di più persone labbra quando ci diamo il
bacio perché si 6 giulia penna sicilia
penalty giulia penna che giulia pensano
giulia penn giulia penda canta come
invece era dai e quindi ragazzi e questo
quello che è successo durante la
settimana spero che vi piace la parodia
perché ci abbiamo lavorato veramente
tanto ma secondo me non lo so ragazzi
spero che video vi sia piaciuto come
assoluto più preciso argomento mi piace
anche i vari social che come l'invito a
donare schizzare ci sono usciti semplici
che diavolo prossimo video per ragazzi